joe kent is a retired army special
forces and former cia paramilitary
officer he joins us now to react to all
of this latest chaos hey joe can you
make sense of this
no there's no sense to be made the only
lesson that we can take here is that we
cannot negotiate with terrorists from a
position of weakness going back to the
obama administration that's been the
lesson the disastrous bergdahl debacle
that put those terrorists back in power
after they got a u.s taxpayer-funded
vacation to gitmo essentially and then
the deal that biden failed to negotiate
with the taliban to get all of the
americans out this just shows that the
culture from the top matters when the
commander-in-chief and the unelected
bureaucrats don't care about america's
standing in the world and they they view
us as just another nation on the decline
this is exactly what happens contrast
that with four years of president trump
and negotiating from a position of power
it's a night and day difference we had
the ability to get all of our people out
under president trump he negotiated a
deal that would have had us out of
afghanistan in the summer of 2020 until
the permanent ruling class the unelected
bureaucrats leaked made up intelligence
about russian bounties that resulted in
the uniparty leaving us in afghanistan
that's exactly how we got to this point
right now they didn't want president
trump's plan to succeed and that put us
in this position of weakness got 13
great soldiers killed and now has
americans being held hostage with our
state department absolutely helpless you
know what's pretty amazing is we told
them to have a diverse inclusive
government and they didn't i'm shocked
they didn't listen we said have an
inclusive government did they not
understand did we not have a translator
oh we tried we got rid of all of them no
excuse me the translators we didn't get
out uh among the other people important
positions is suraj haqqani who is he a
designated global terrorist by
washington who we have on a wanted list
for 10 million dollars so we couldn't
get that glossy headshot from him so we
were forced to use the wanted photo we
had up how's that going for inclusive
it's absolutely ridiculous and that just
speaks to the relationship that we've
had with pakistan once again when we
negotiate from a position of weakness
that only lines the pockets of these
corrupt governments and lobbyists in
washington dc people like saraj haqqani
can hide out on the pakistani border
kidnap americans
run
terrorism operations seek sanctuary with
people that we're providing us aid to
even when they get caught red-handed
hosting bin laden there we still
continue to pour us aid into them we
need a massive amount of accountability
our government and our permanent ruling
class is an absolute disgrace to all the
lives that have been lost over there
that's exactly why i'm running for
congress to bring accountability to our
permanent ruling class that's why i was
honored that president trump provided me
with his endorsement to bring the
america first agenda back to put an end
to all this excessive waste in all of
the lives being taken by the hubris and
the
the uh hubris and lies of our permanent
ruling class joe the thing is i really
think we needed somewhat of a presence
in the area i did not want to give it
right to the terrorists and already one
of the people infecting the new uh
taliban government directly linked to
al-qaeda he was the liaison between the
two uh back which led to the 9 11
attacks keep in mind too sue gordon
who's the deputy director of national
intelligence said this about our future
intelligence
operations we have to use some
non-traditional partners now to find out
what's happening in the region jot this
down
russia china iran and pakistan will have
to be our eyes and ears in the region
can you please tell me what joe biden
was doing for the last 50 years that he
brought us this mess
no that's an absolute lie we have the
ability to collect intelligence without
having a permanent military presence
there without propping up these made up
governments the problem is limited
intelligence operations limited
counterterrorism operations they don't
provide income for the military
industrial complex so you're hearing all
these folks that are the so-called
adults in the room the so-called experts
in washington dc saying well now we just
have to accept the fact that we're a
power and decline and we're going to
rely on all these other powers in
decline and this is just the way that it
is unless we go back in so that's the
problem right now that we have we're
presented with this binary choice it's
absolutely false that's exactly why i'm
running for congress to change this and
to bring some accountability to
washington d.c the good news is joan i
think you agree we have good war
fighters our commanders do not live up
to our warfighters deserve and they're
ready to go and we got the best r d
people on the planet so we don't have
far to go we just need better leadership
joe kent best of luck in your race
that's exactly right thank you very much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else